for sure hi I'm Tyler I worked at IKEA
for a year and my name is Elise I worked
at IKEA for about eight months
hey guys me with turns up in IKEA for
two years my name is Jonathan I worked
at IKEA for 11 months and we're gonna
play never have I ever
oh yeah I am
me too let's forget like are you
supposed to win or lose I don't about to
find out right now okay all right
question number one never have I ever
gotten lost in the store all the time no
I haven't like I said there's you can
like read their signs I have not Wow
okay Oh arrows on the ground you ding
right yeah there are arrows it took me
about a month to learn about the arrows
never have I ever slept on the furniture
I have not slept on the furniture
neither have I we are very good
coworkers yeah I have
I would actually is a video of me in the
back of home delivery and it was me and
I'm a Carhartt Trisha me attrition was
in the back you know fooling around and
if I got counted swear I wasn't
returning I know what I was doing
supposed to be a nasty but anywho there
was a dance going at the time the little
okay where are the story I got into the
freaking so because I believe it's super
soft like a super song as soon as I hit
this I thought it right me and the
little couch go right off together it
was a blast
no I see cuz like every people touch it
and it's like a lot of people that like
come through the store every day I'm
like
mmm I'm good never have I ever not known
where something was but gave directions
anyway constantly all the time when I
first started I don't know where the
hell the damn bathroom I said people
upstairs to LP is upstairs to the
parking lot I remember like when I
started and like because you're wearing
that uniform so it's like people are
gonna come and ask you questions and
like if you point in a direction like
the store goes in a circle anyway so if
you just keep going in the direction
you're probably gonna get the product
that you asked for
never have I ever mispronounced a
product a product
probably have I honestly wouldn't know
if I did or not Swedish is a hot
language yes it's Swedish people speak
English so well so it's very
embarrassing as a native English speaker
that we can't adopt the language easily
but I had dots over all their letters I
know I don't understand that alphabet
there's all kind of like symbols and
signs let's go
the M eg this is and this is why I refer
to items by article not because I know
how to pronounce 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
never have I ever been yelled at by a
customer like how many more do we have
anymore these in the back we both work
in the return section and that's like
like guaranteed like
guaranteed it's our fault that they
don't have their Racine I have been
yelled at my customer quite a few
customers it's mainly whenever I tell
them that I can't sell them display
items oh never get a display never get a
display item if it's not in a box we
cannot sell it and not for you therefore
display people get upset because they
have to go back to the store in the law
long I don't know they don't the way
mining it but thank you have to go
through this tour again we just
sometimes worse I can't understand why
that would be frustrating - yeah - you
think you're done and the the light of
the outside is just over the beacon and
then you find out you have to go all the
way back and out of the line I
understand why that is frustrating but
also it's I display I desire sometimes
that I fear you're making people's
dreams but sometimes you're breaking
them never have I ever eaten the Swedish
meatballs dem job is a good job you know
I have in there delicious meatballs I
got chicken meatballs they got veggie
balls balls you won't they got okay go
get your balls be bombs big fan of the
meatballs I cannot stress this enough
sometimes they have a deal focus in
sometimes they have a deal where it's 20
dollars for three bags of meatballs that
is so many meatballs please get that
deal I never actually ate the food I
heard that um that they don't actually
make a profit on the food sales but
customers knowing IKEA I was having like
cheap food gives like the brand
recognition of being like affordable so
so the food is actually like a marketing
technique never have I ever injured
myself at work you have it did I play
those games there's a line that is I am
baffled so when you return all those
little dresses from you like me machine
no no young clothes in the cards the
cards didn't need to change at all oh
maybe once the card maybe hit my shin
okay it would turn there but I didn't
get injured it's just like it's like did
it hurt though no no I don't play never
have I ever goofed off in the store
after hours when it's time to go it's
not to go I'm a victim of a victim
well is the one who playing with the
spare parts then they'll be up in the
carts all up up and down the aisles then
they'll be having fun baby then their
loves IKEA okay I'll be on the counters
the music at night
have you heard but do you have a phone
account those carts are so fun to like
ride on there but like that's that's
safe
yeah and we're on that's just doing work
in a creative way and Fossum yeah parts
back exactly and you're getting there
Foster it's efficient I will have a
concert like two what a song comes on
but like stay after hours not only do I
consider after hours the customers going
we still there amen that's even more
time to go like let me cash l let me go
home if you do a quick throw you have
time to fool around
no you have time to go home so that's
our game of never have I ever looking at
a Kia there's a fun place to work
it is still a job so even got to do it's
got to do to survive make it out alive
super fun job had a great time still go
there a lot yeah I still have fun
memories like what he and I can't was
probably like the highlight of my youth
everybody's record IKEA IKEA it's
freaking cool as hell and yes go get
your coin in secure your bags okay
[Music]